[Música]
el presidente giovanni inauguró
oficialmente la novena cumbre de las
américas y apelo a la democracia como el
ingrediente esencial del continente de
mandatarios recibió a los jefes de
gobierno y de estado de varios países
para el evento que se extenderá hasta el
próximo viernes 10 de junio
la cámara baja del congreso de eeuu
aprobó una iniciativa para reforzar los
controles en la venta de armas la medida
bautizada protejamos a nuestros niños
propone aumentar de 18 a 21 años la edad
permitida para comprar armas
semiautomáticas y pruebe también los
cartuchos de gran capacidad de balas
la ciudad ucraniana de severodonezk está
en gran medida controlada por las tropas
rusas según dijo su gobernador por su
parte el presidente voló de excelencia y
señaló que en esa urbe se decide el
destino de la región del donbass en
medio de los combates y alertó sobre la
intensidad de los enfrentamientos
hola bienvenidos a una nueva emisión de
noticias en france 24 los saluda andrés
meza muñoz
empezamos en eeuu con un discurso el
presidente joe biden inauguró
oficialmente la novena cumbre de las
américas en la ciudad de los ángeles a
la que asisten jefes de gobierno y
estado del continente el mandatario hizo
énfasis en la democracia y la calificó
como un sello distintivo de occidente y
advirtió que ésta está bajo ataque
precisamente la carta democrática fue la
excusa de la administración baiden para
no invitar a cuba nicaragua y venezuela
a la cumbre escuchamos
cuando la democracia está siendo atacada
en todo el mundo unámonos de nuevo en
una nueva convicción que la democracia
no es sólo una característica que define
la historia de américa sino es un
ingrediente esencial de américa
en otras noticias de eeuu la cámara de
representantes votó una propuesta que
busca establecer una edad mínima de 21
años para comprar armas semiautomáticas
el proyecto de ley contiene las medidas
más duras para limitar las armas que se
ha aprobado en décadas en la cámara baja
es corona para aquellos que creen que un
momento de silencio suficiente porque no
tienen el coraje de votar para proteger
a los niños diría que su supervivencia
política es totalmente insignificante en
comparación con la supervivencia de
nuestros niños
son insto a mis colegas de ambos lados
del pasillo a que se unan con un fuerte
voto a favor de todas las disposiciones
del proyecto de ley para el paquete
final y que lo hagan como parte de una
cruzada de por iu para los niños
entre tanto sobrevivientes y familiares
de las víctimas de la masacre de
valdepero pidieron a los miembros del
congreso de eeuu que hicieran más esto
ocurrió durante una audiencia que
nuevamente terminó sin conclusiones más
en el siguiente informe del mar esa
autodefensa o una puerta abierta a la
tragedia desde estos dos puntos de vista
se abordó el tema del acceso a las armas
durante una audiencia en la comisión de
supervisión de la cámara de
representantes en la que también se
escucharon las voces de sobrevivientes
de los fallecidos en la reciente masacre
de oval de donde un tirador de 18 años
acabó con la vida de 19 niños y dos
maestras
pero lo que sí encontré fue algo que
ninguna oración aliviará jamás dos niños
cuyos cuerpos habían sido pulverizados
por las balas que le dispararon
decapitados cuyas carnes habían sido
desgarradas
cuando fui hacia los bolsos él le
disparó a mi amigo que estaba cerca de
mí y pensé que él iba a regresar al
cuarto así que agarré la sangre y la
puse toda sobre mí
y qué hiciste cuando te pusiste toda la
sangre encima
me quedé quieta y toma el teléfono de mi
maestra y llamé al 911
aún con la contundencia de los
testimonios el debate continuó abierto
entre quienes apoyan y quienes siguen
rechazando el control de armas porque
existe un lugar importante para que los
propietarios de armas respetuosos de la
ley sirvan para protegerse a sí mismos a
sus familias ya sus comunidades de la
violencia las reacciones instintivas
para imponer políticas de control de
armas no son la respuesta a figuras como
el actor más imaginativo de balde y el
alcalde de nueva york eric adams quien
abogó por una solución a la violencia
armada se hicieron presentes en la
audiencia es hora de decidir si es más
importante proteger las ganancias de los
fabricantes de armas o la vida de
nuestros niños ruth el panel del
congreso se reunió mientras un grupo
bipartidista de senadores negocia para
ver si hay forma de alcanzar algún
compromiso sobre la seguridad de las
armas que demócratas y republicanos
puedan aceptar
seguimos allí en eeuu porque decenas de
gimnastas de este país entre las que
está la medallista de oro olímpica simón
bailes reclaman mil millones de dólares
al fbi la agencia no detuvo en 2015 al
ex médico del equipo nacional la heroína
se pese a haber recibido denuncias de
abusos sexuales una negligencia que hizo
que decenas de deportistas continuarán
siendo abusadas informe de luís muñoz
las gimnastas estadounidenses contra el
fbi más de 90 mujeres reclamaron más de
1000 millones de dólares a la agencia
gubernamental en denuncias dirigidas a
ex agentes por haber entorpecido la
investigación contra el médico deportivo
la reina sar abusador del equipo
nacional de gimnasia así lo manifestó de
forma pública una de las abogadas si las
entidades y los individuos no están
motivados por el amor y lo que es
correcto deben existir consecuencias
para motivar el cambio el fracaso del
fbi tuvo consecuencias devastadoras para
sobrevivientes como ellos no se ocuparán
de ello nosotros lo haremos orgullosa de
estas mujeres el fbi tendrá seis meses
para responder las demandantes se basan
en la ley federal de reclamos por
agravios ésta establece que las personas
lesionadas por negligencia u omisión
estatal deben ser compensadas por el
gobierno en abril 13 gimnastas ya
presentaron reclamos por 130 millones de
dólares
un informe de julio de 2021 del
inspector general del departamento de
justicia reveló errores generalizados y
graves del fbi la agencia ya tenía
conocimiento de las denuncias
permitieron que un abusador de niños
quedara en libertad durante más de un
año esta inacción permitió directamente
que continuara el abuso de nasal chic
ingenio este estado este es el caso más
grande de abuso sexual en la historia
del deporte estadounidense sin embargo
hace dos semanas el departamento de
justicia dijo que mantenía su decisión
de no presentar cargos contra los
agentes negligentes como la medallista
de oro olímpica simón bailes la reina
sar fue condenado a entre 40 y 175 años
de cárcel por abusar a más de 330
jóvenes ya otros 60 años por pornografía
infantil en condenas emitidas entre
diciembre de 2017 y febrero de 2018
y ahora vamos con información de la
guerra en ucrania según el gobernador de
lugansk gran parte de la ciudad de
severodonezk está ahora en manos de las
tropas rusas la urbe se ha convertido en
un foco estratégico de la ofensiva del
kremlin ya que sería clave para hacerse
con el control de la región del donbass
mientras tanto su ciudad gemela lisis
suns que está sufriendo una enorme
destrucción el presidente ucraniano
volodymyr selenski dijo que el futuro de
esta región dependerá de las batallas
que se libren severodonezk y alertó
sobre la intensidad de los combates en
la zona
severodonezk sigue siendo el epicentro
de combates en el donbass como resultado
de ese día y noche ya el día 105 de una
guerra a gran escala estamos defendiendo
nuestras posiciones y estamos
infringiendo pérdidas tangibles al
enemigo esta es una batalla muy brutal
muy dura quizás una de las más difíciles
de toda esta guerra estoy agradecido con
todos y cada uno de los que están
defendiendo en gran medida ahí es donde
se está decidiendo ahora el destino de
nuestro bombas summertime sarsfield
mayor dan vaso el secretario general de
la onu antonio guterres alertó sobre la
posibilidad de que la guerra en ucrania
produzca una ola de hambre y miseria sin
precedentes acompañada de caos social y
económico las afirmaciones de guterres
tuvieron lugar durante la presentación
del segundo informe del grupo de
respuesta a la crisis mundial que hace
énfasis en los efectos del conflicto en
ucrania el secretario general explicó
que este año la crisis se puede ver
reflejada en el difícil acceso a los
alimentos pero que de continuar la
guerra el año que viene podría ser un
escenario más complicado ante la escases
de alimentos la crisis alimentaria
afecta principalmente a mujeres y
menores de edad
nah son joaquín garcía líder y
autodenominado apóstol de la iglesia la
luz del mundo fue sentenciado en los
ángeles a 16 años y 8 meses de prisión
después de su condena por delitos graves
de abuso sexual a tres niñas garcía se
declaró culpable el viernes pasado de
abuso sexual infantil tres días antes de
que fuera a juicio por violación cargos
de trata de personas y pornografía
infantil y por ello la fiscalía de
california recomendó una pena más baja
por su parte sus acusadores calificaron
la decisión como demasiado indulgente
en las autoridades sanitarias de brasil
confirmaron el primer caso de la viruela
del mono en su territorio se trata de un
paciente de 41 años que viajó a sao
paulo desde españa uno de los países más
afectados por el virus de acuerdo con el
informe oficial
el hombre fue aislado desde que presentó
los primeros síntomas solo hasta el
pasado lunes había siete casos
sospechosos en varios estados del país
en américa latina argentina confirmados
y mexico 1 y en total ya habría más de
1000 casos a nivel mundial según la
organización mundial de la salud
hasta que este informativo gracias por
acompañarnos
[Música]